The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
You're recharging.
Retard.
Ooh,
Ooh.
All right.
Shane Smith,
2013 the soapy is say the last one is [inaudible] nine three years of all.
Be here to see it.
See you next week.
We've got to quit.
That was as good as we've ever done.
What we should do right now.
Let's move to Seattle.
We should move to the Wilderness area where they filmed the very first twilight.
Be
Good.
I'll tell you though.
As far as how as the fair,
I think that was good though.
That was fun.
I don't think we've heard that about a podcast.
I agree.
I mean,
I know we were fucked up,
but I think that,
I think people are going to say that was,
it was really good.
Was there one moment where you felt like this was the wrong thing to do?
No,
no.
It's fine.
No,
it,
it was fun.
That was the damn perfect ride down the side of a mountain
sledding.
Million miles an hour off.
I might be as good as we're capable of those.
We might go towards higher.
We may have to just do that once a week and we might have to go skiing for God.
That was like the most,
I think you were,
you were,
you were like,
oh,
I was going to say,
you're like some existential apart from talks or her people who shouldn't even
fucking know what existentialism is.
Well,
don't I always explain the way you know some of them,
like they get deep enough.
So let me explain myself.
Sorry,
I'm the,
I'm the bridge between the meatheads and upon.
That's exactly my bread.
And by the way,
people out there,
your audience understands that we're doing shit in a different way and you're
doing shit.
That's fucking awesome.
You're going to Munster off to do the fucking fight.
But at the same time you here doing fucking podcast.
Talk to me about how the fuck no one's ever done that before.
I don't believe no one's ever done it before in the history of frumpy media.
Yeah,
but it's not because it wasn't there.
I don't think it's been there.
Why did they,
I don't think he's been there.
I honestly believe that closure of the exposure two information gets broader and
we're all going to get swept into this sort of wave of information and wave of
exposure to information.
I think concentrating on where the information is being tuned into or where it's
being drawn,
cast is not
the most important thing.
What you're doing has never been done.
Yes and no.
You don't never be done,
but you know you've never had four g internet before.
I don't know how that boy who is doing what you're doing,
it has never been.
I understand.
I mean it's fucking fantastic.
Yeah,
I understand,
but it's not.
It's all we're doing is letting me know shit that's happening.
Do it was not as,
not a lot of doing because it's never been done and it's fantastic.
No,
I said that the last podcast.
I couldn't say it then.
That'd be it.
But what you're doing is that it's fine.
Well,
we're lucky that we're in a position to do it,
but it's with what anybody would do.
They logically look to the situation and realize this or
no,
you're doing a man.
What you're doing has never been done.
Yeah,
but it's not because it's that hard or it's that is.
There's no resistance to doing Brian,
here's the reality,
right?
I don't feel any resistance to doing this this way.
Do you know
this is the Austin?
How?
How have you been doing what you guys are doing?
How's that?
Never been done?
Look at Howard Stern.
Howard stern used to be the uncensored king of all media.
Nowadays,
he's like fucking TV news compared to like what podcast can I say one thing?
You're a guy who's like you already.
You've made your shit.
You got your shit,
you got your gigs,
you got all your stuff,
and you're taking that and you're using that to do something different.
Something that no one's ever done before and listen,
no man,
no.
Press that button all until it beeps,
beeps,
you know,
hotel last women don't,
don't even breathing yet.
Keep squeezing.
Keep it together.
Won't,
don't get anything.
I'll just squeeze it.
Don't,
don't even stock yet.
Hold,
squeeze,
hold,
hold.
Is he the woods and the roads
shut up by the way,
thing for birds.
I love that
you made your money made make with other people,
George Clooney,
everyone goes up.
You actually go out there and you put people on your fucking podcast as fucking
important is fucking important.
Well,
I know we've talked about this.
I don't care what you say.
It's fucking important when you're doing,
and by the way,
do you have a huge audience,
which is fucking,
and what we're talking about a lot of it's weird,
but a lot of it is we're talking about shit to no one knows I'm talking about,
come on.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Okay.
Yes,
I did fine,
but it's not,
it looked as a lot of people that did it before me.
All I did was pick up the ball and let everybody know that.
I think that if you can,
if you can justify your position or your reasoning for looking at things,
if you can talk to a group of strangers and manic and be honest about where
you're coming from,
that it's important to do well.
I think it's important just to have a point of view that,
uh,
that,
that makes sense with the information you've been allowed to have access to.
But if you've been allowed to have access to a lot of shit and you kind of made
mistakes or they fucked up and you see people making the same mistakes,
it's really important to step up and look,
where are you?
Yes.
Don't worry to,
we're just fucking trying to just say we're fucking regular again.
You're not going to have a bunch of,
right.
You're a fucking dude.
You made your shit.
You fucking hit your fucking thing.
But still you're,
you're,
you're doing these podcasts and by the way,
every time
the fewer of positivity that comes up,
I'm going to say this,
we talked about a lot of fucked up shit and these people are like,
what?
You're fucking at least your tone.
The partners who might be wasted,
we might be fucked up movie talking crazy shit,
but in fact they're saying you don't want your fucking gentleman the truth,
and I'm going to say this,
that's important.
That's fucking important.
I agree with you.
I think it's important whenever people express the ideas of a sort of universal
French people who follow,
you
are the people we need because what they're doing,
they're afraid they curved or fortune.
People are saying,
fuck everything called the bullshit.
I've never had a more positive reaction.
Anything I've ever done
this fucking
great.
But it's bizarre.
It's bizarre.
It's great.
It is great,
but is also bizarre.
It's great in the fact that it's a how about how you have the full MMA guys are
the freest thinkers we have out there.
You would think that that's unusual,
but me as a guy who's done martial arts or whole life,
uh,
I think that it's a,
that's how it's supposed to be,
but I think it's not a mistake and not a coincidence that the very best guys at
the top of the heat or also what I would consider martial artists like Anderson
Silva beforehand,
the homeless,
different spot in the
are going to happen.
Listen.
And Nick Diaz is how my life that I like
mother pass this.
Brian.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
Diaz guys,
listen,
I love both of these guys.
I love George and I love nick and I look of fight and I love the idea behind it
because the idea behind is you taking the very best in the world,
best in the world.
These guys are the Iliad GSP because he seems like he's also a bunch of,
he is also a real martial artists.
The Way Anderson Silva is,
you know the way we know them,
the Cheetah is the way,
even John Jones,
I love Jon Jones.
They aspire to be martial arts.
I've been watching
UFC
fight land is
the very first step.
So Dustin employee and worked on the carpet.
Just stories I understanding,
you know,
how are we doing a good job when we show we did an amazing job.
Listen,
you could tell me for fucking hot.
I would,
I'd like you to know I'm going to actually,
you know,
tell us and if we're doing something wrong to tell us because I would listen to
how they look at whatever you want me to look at it.
If you ever want to meet you too,
I'll be very happy.
I want you to say I'm want to do it so I'm fine
whenever you want want to do this.
I'm saying if I just don't want to be a shithead off.
I like cause our guys they love.
How about you and me do a breakdown of the individual martial arts.
What I would love if people would do whatever and weaker and highway 83 love
whatever.
Let's tell you why.
Because I think what we have to do,
what our job is,
when we do escape surf,
we took core and we did with the PDF
and indeed we're doing it now with the soccer.
We,
we take core core MMA fans of the craziest fans,
but we have to take it to crossover,
right?
To take it to cross over to other people and what you are,
you're the best crossover guy in the fucking world.
Cause you're saying I'm an MMA guy but I'm actually smarter than no shit.
And if I could talk about the fucking philosophy,
my advice.
Ready?
Yes.
Forget it all.
Ignore it.
Do it to like put it on what you're like,
forget all the bullshit.
But whatever it shows,
they either you're interested in any conversation here and I'd love to do is
take it from that of MMA and bring it up to the crossover and say,
this isn't fucking just these guys.
It's like if you look at John Jones and you say,
okay,
this guy is a fucking ease,
Muhammad Ali,
he's the,
he's the modern day Bahama.
The only difference between him and Muhammad Ali because he doesn't have 50
fucking documentaries.
I'm a boring,
no,
I'm trying to figure out what it was,
but the different things on,
so he has massive,
just unbelievable like fountains in mountains and fields of potential,
but he's only,
but when I saw him fighting for,
I think it's 25 but when I saw him fight,
I was like,
this guy is so far ahead of everybody else and he's so much better than
everybody else.
But also his stories guy.
He's a smart guy.
And the whole thing of like when he won the championship,
the choking out the person.
Like it was like two hours.
And I'm like,
yeah,
right.
And I'm like,
okay,
if we had that on film,
this is what we sold to two UFC is we should have,
we should have had him choking out a fucking purse.
Snatcher in New Jersey before he went to went the fucking check.
Right.
You mean if you guys were there while he was exactly right now and now we have
that access.
Right.
My whole thing is for anybody who does and you sell them on Ebay doesn't
understand.
We're talking about Jon Jones before he fought for the UFC light heavyweight
title,
like the day of the fight,
it was meditating in a park in New Jersey and he saw some guys snatch someone's
purse and he was crying like Spiderman,
like literally like Peter Parker.
Literally.
He went over and he took down this,
so he crossed it out.
He ran after him.
Choke him out in mid stride.
Yeah,
of course.
The purse bag then to thank you very much and went on to win the fucking shit
and you're like,
hold on a second.
Hold on a second.
That's the greatest story in fighting ever.
Reverse Parker,
let the,
the the criminal past five and then he killed his uncle Ben.
And that's what haunted Peter Parker and make him be so,
and this guy is literally like Muhammad Ali going to go fight for his title.
He choked down to fucking prison in New Jersey.
Yeah.
Choked him out,
gave him to the cops and said two hours later I'm going to go fucking fight for
the championship of the world.
And by the way,
one,
and I'm going to say that's a great story.
It's a great story.
But that was going on free to go to go one more step you with what you do,
fear factor,
what you've done with MMA,
what you've done,
what you should,
and still doing these podcasts is fucking,
that's very important.
It's very important.
And by the way,
if you say it's not important,
I'm going to punch you in the salmon work.
No cause you're [inaudible]
need conscious.
I'm not afraid of,
you need a lot of efforts.
Let's say aim.
And I just say this then
I respect you.
I,
I completely respect the idea that you're trying to put for,
I respect and I respect,
and now we're finished,
right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Okay.
Yeah.